greets everyone I'm Alana and today I'm
talking about something that a bunch of
you probably already know about not by
my choice that kind of went public a
year ago but at the time I decided not
to say anything
mostly for my own safety and just
because I didn't want to make the
situation any worse than it already was
there are three reasons why I decided to
talk about this right now one on one of
my recent videos someone screenshotted a
comment from a guy who was mad at me for
having a boyfriend
and it got to the top of ah nice guys I
think and I genuinely was mostly just
entertained by it that comment did not
bother me at all and I was so shocked by
the amount of responses of people who
are disgusted or amazed that these kinds
of comments exist to the extent that I
was kind of like wait you guys don't
know how common this [ __ ] is and that's
not even an internet thing it's it's an
ownership thing the whole friendzone
thing so that was the first reason as
people were amazed by this threat that I
was like oh you guys don't know how much
this happens or how extreme this gets
number two was that I've always wanted
to share my side of this um people have
commented on my post asking me from my
side of this for a long time now that
it's over a year ago I don't feel so bad
about it and then the third reason is
actually because of them the me to
social media campaign that's been going
on at the moment so this is kind of like
sparring from that it was a situation
where I felt like this is a thing that I
went through that ended up being awkward
in public that people don't realize has
happened to a lot of people so about two
years ago this guy started commenting
regularly on my Social Feeds
I cannot pinpoint the time when that
happened because I don't remember and
there's a lot of people who do that he
started a comment regularly enough that
I would recognize his name which for the
record was always Bruce Wayne on social
media he never used his real name when
talking to me I never had any idea who
he was he never had real profiles it was
always a person going by a fake name
with a penguin as their profile picture
so someone that I never had any way of
identifying and I still anyone who was
asked me do not know his name do not
have any contact with him don't know
where he lives or what his number is
people have been like hey you should
check up on him like you should make
sure he's okay I don't have any way of
contacting him at all so he was just a
guy who would comment on my Social Feeds
regularly and I didn't really think
anything of it I guess it started
happening more and more often and he was
always I guess nice just a little
overbearing and as has happened with
several people that I've been in this
situation with it'll eventually get to a
point where I'll be like hey your
comments are a little too intense
they never react well to that I can be
like hey you're a little bit of the top
with how affectionate you're being
towards me and it's making me
uncomfortable and they will always go
full 180 and hate me intensely and
dedicate those social feeds to how much
they hate me because I've tried as
politely as possible to be like you're
weirding me out this sucks this didn't
happen with him I told him to calm down
and he would be really offended and then
just completely ignore it but he didn't
ever hog 180 on me or dedicate his
accounts to how much he hated me so it's
like I had already built up a profile of
this guy and was aware of what he was
saying and he was telling a line or I
was like this is getting a little
uncomfortable and I slowly started to
block him off my social media kind of
one by one based on stuff he was saying
but the thing that officially crossed
the line and made me block him off of
Facebook which is the place where he was
most active in talking to me I think
outside of YouTube was that I got my
eyebrows tattooed and I shared that on
snapchat for context basically what that
means is that my eyebrows are real I did
not get my eyebrows shaped off I have
like just it's called micro bleeding
pretty common practice wasn't a huge
deal to me but he ended up going
on IGN videos which is the company that
I work for and if people would say
something nice about me he would reply
to them and be like um she got her
eyebrows tattooed basically he was
incredibly angry that someone he had put
on an unrealistic pedestal had done
something to themselves that he didn't
like and that was the point where I was
like hold up at this point you about
policing what I can do to my body and
you want angry when I do something you
don't like I don't even know your
goddamn name so that was the point that
I was like this is too possessive and
too controlling and too overbearing so I
thought to mele deleted him blocked him
from everything he's still commented on
some of my white videos and I couldn't
really stop him from doing that so I had
one of my co-workers reply to him and
say hey I wanna doesn't want you to
contact her anymore please consider the
same warning or whatever he made another
Facebook account trying to convince me
to unban him and I know what it invented
him so it was just like a thing where I
was like this needs to stop this is not
good so as a response to that he made
reddit threads about me one of them was
effectively asking if he could get in
trouble for stalking if he made more
accounts under more fake names he was
legitimately asking people for advice on
like hey how close can I get to stalking
her without legally getting into any
trouble he sent letters to my workplace
he also said that he was planning to
call the front desk at IGN and have them
transfer to me to the phone on my desk
so we got rid of the phone on my desk so
that wasn't an option and there was also
a threat regarding III that year in 2016
so I had to just giant terrifying
looking security gods walking around
with me for the entirety of last year's
e3 just to make sure that nothing we had
happened so I found out about these
reddit threads because someone already
reported it to IGN security and IGN did
try to get reddit to take the threads
down so that people would stop talking
to me about it and stop we can get and
sharing it reddit said no which I
understand but it should
also he mentioned that he posted one two
three four five he posted five threads
about the same thing so the thing that
really gets me is the stuff that he
commented on um ready the stuff that he
said to people which he now said to me I
had no way of knowing any of this one of
them was like thanks for the advice but
I'm going to keep sending her letters
which I guess is a response to a person
saying don't do this and he said the guy
on the movie the notebooks had like 365
letters to that go I feel like if I send
them for long enough she will realize
how much I care about her and maybe she
will be friends with me then uh he also
references Game of Thrones at one point
he's like in Game of Thrones Daenerys
banishes Jorah twice and he came back
both times too we know back that's how I
feel about her eventually she will see
this an unbanned me and I just really
want to say to anyone who might be
watching this who doesn't understand
this and I'm trying to say it in the
Politis way possible because I get that
people don't understand these things and
we shouldn't necessarily ridicule them
for it if you are making someone
uncomfortable and it's clear that you've
made them uncomfortable because they
banned you you are effectively
intimidating someone by just repeatedly
doing a thing that they don't like and I
really think movies have told people
that this works that if you don't give
up on trying to get the girl to like you
she will eventually give in that's gross
that's not how that works don't do that
so then when he made the reddit post
specifically about if you could stalk me
on Facebook people said this is probably
illegal
in the state of California and he said
it should be illegal for her to block me
like that she will make people kill
themself being that mean that should be
illegal and that's where people got most
mad at me people treated me like I had
done the wrong thing but what would you
have done what do you do in this
circumstance trust me when you tell
people that they're making you
uncomfortable that's when they start
sending you death threats that's when
you see an entire Instagram feed that is
dedicated to them hating you screenshots
of your face slathered in swear words it
just doesn't work so then after that I
guess all of this discussion with people
on reddit asking this guy to get help
and to
not make another account was when people
told him that I had a boyfriend
he kept saying stuff like no she's
single this is a lie this guy he's
making this up I guess this was back
when we were a little bit more private
about our relationship but people were
absolutely correct in telling him that I
had a boyfriend and he didn't take that
well what's wrong is when a girl makes
you fall in love with them then
completely crushes you by calling you a
creep and banning you for no reason then
publicly humiliates you online that's
wrong not what I did the context I never
called him a creep I did not make any
effort to publicly humiliate him I never
even spoke about this publicly he did
that was humiliating for me so then
amidst all of this stuff about me having
a boyfriend he said how would you feel
if your girlfriend found someone else
she likes more than you that's how I
feel and then the last two comments I'll
most likely be dead tonight so that
should make her extremely happy and then
[ __ ] this world and then he didn't use
the account again I don't know what
happened
I don't have any way of knowing what
happened I don't like thinking about it
and I don't know that there's a way that
I could approach this differently and I
feel like there is a chance that he
ended up making a fake account and still
talks to me because I am an idiot and
replied away too many people on the
internet and I just don't know and if
you are watching this video please just
know that this isn't how relationships
work relationships aren't one person
manipulating the other person throwing
compliments at them and then the other
person loving them that's not what our
relationship is stop thinking you're
entitled to someone's time because you
were nice to them especially when nice
is like the base level of what a human
should be and I really think of all of
my experiences with guys who said that I
have friends on them all of them were
people who want nice who referred to
themselves as nice
guys when in reality they were clingy
and possessive and jealous and they
thought that because they were so
overbearing that was kindness and it's
not I just want people to stop taking
that forceful thing that happens in
movies and thinking then it happens in
real life because that's how people end
up in this situation that's how girls
get shot when doing fan meetups that's
why I feel like I need security every
time I go to an event now which
absolutely sucks that's why I will not
walk around a show floor unless I have
people with me anymore I wish I had
something more positive or uplifting to
say but this [ __ ] happens a lot and it's
scary
thank you all for watching this video I
hope it was I don't know insightful in
some way have to give it an extra thanks
to everyone who's been supporting me on
patreon when YouTube completely stopped
supporting my channel but on patreon
this week we are talking about Blade
Runner
20:49 so check that out and yeah thank
you to the people whose names are on
screen right now already I will see
y'all next time okay